welcome back oh
we are so hot to trot for interior
design on this show it was one of my big
missions i was like could we please do a
lot of design because that is where i'm
confident it is where i love to spread
my wings i think it affects us
emotionally and spiritually and mentally
to make our spaces something that as
marie kondo says sparks joy and that's
why i was over the moon when one of our
viewers reached out
with wanting some help with the living
space
that we have yet to tackle on this show
and it's certainly a space i know
something about let's meet jenna
hi my name is jenna trocchio i live in
wall new jersey with my wonderful
husband nick trokio and we are expecting
our first baby i've been a special ed
language arts teacher for 13 years my
parents were teachers i could see from
my parents teaching in elementary in the
high school the impact that they made on
kids and that's just something i always
wanted to do 13 years later i'm still
loving it i work with great people
because of the pandemic we have a lot of
extra hours planning
work to do to catch up from the last few
years that we lost but it's worth it we
love the kids they're amazing and you
know from working with them throughout
all the years it just makes me want to
start my own family and create this new
chapter in our life and nick and i
couldn't be more excited to welcome our
baby boy
it's been crazy it's been hectic nick
and i just bought our forever home
there's so much to do and
not enough time the nursery is the last
piece of the puzzle and we want to
welcome our baby boy in such a beautiful
place so drew we desperately need your
help with this nursery
yes
thank you for giving me this opportunity
i had a chance to meet jenna on zoom and
i let her in on a little surprise take a
look at our conversation
[Music]
hi jenna oh my gosh hi drew how are you
doing you're eight months yes i'm 35
weeks today congratulations to you and
your husband nicholas thank you so much
we appreciate it so i am the mother of
two daughters i am a passionate designer
i'm lucky enough on this show to have
this amazing partner in design crime
mikael welch and
we took a look at your nursery
and we would like with your permission
to design it for you oh my gosh thank
you so much i can't believe this well
there is a company stoka and in the baby
gear world they are at the top of their
game and your room is going to be
amazing because of them and am i correct
in that you prefer
neutrals more to bright colors yes you
like neutral cozy
and not to be a cliche but i went with
some blue tones and some grays
and
some creams perfect if you can have a
zen calm pretty space
it'll help with all the chaos and beauty
that's about to ensue buckle up your
entire life is about to change
it's so amazing no one can prepare you
for it but the one thing i can say is
that i thought i knew what love was but
i learned what love is through my kids
well thank you for letting me do this
with you especially at this most
auspicious time thank you so much this
is incredible i'm so excited all right
i'll speak to you soon we're knee-deep
in the process that's coming along
beautifully we can't wait thank you drew
speak soon
well off to work we went and this
project is so special to me because we
teamed up with children's furniture and
accessories brand stoka to give jenna
the nursery of her dreams stoka has the
most beautifully designed functional
products i mean they're not only
stunning but they're really high quality
premium they also encourage children to
become self-reliant and confident
learners as they grow i'm just so happy
that they would do this with us
okay so much went into this design and
just wait until you see jenna's reaction
after the break and the design and the
whole life that's about to begin with
this space we'll be right back i'm so
excited
[Applause]
[Music]
you